ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung wir
haben wie immer zu Beginn des
begriffsnetz was wir uns anschauen
wollen und Sie werden sehen es wird von
mal zumal immer dichter also wir haben
gesagt menschliches Tier oder Personen
das die Frage individuelle Person oder
kollektive Person
kollektives Tier ist ein bisschen
schwierig vorzustellen Handlungen möchte
ich jetzt ein bisschen weiter
ausdifferenzieren also sie haben
komplexe Handlung basishandlung das
haben wir alles besprochen dann möchte
ich noch unterscheiden zwischen drei
Arten von Handlungen dann müssen auch
noch genauer diskutieren darüber nämlich
die äußere Handlung das ist das was man
gemeinhin unter Handlung versteht wenn
Sie etwas tun also wenn es irgendwie in
der Außenwelt an Tieren und irgendwas
bewegen in Bewegung setzen seine äußere
Handlung kann man sagen dann kann man
aber auch noch eine innere Handlung
unterscheiden damals letzten Endes über
diskutiert wie sieht's aus wenn ich
meinen Willen Willen nicht Bilde das was
Harry fängt verdammt das sollte man als
eine innere Handlung beziehen da
passiert nichts außen mit unseren Händen
sondern das passiert gewissermaßen in
unserem Kopf oder in unserem Willen da
können wir auch irgendwas tun und wir
können auch noch zwischen
Sprachhandlungen unterscheiden das haben
wir das letzte mal kurz angerissen und
da kommen wir heute auch genauer drauf
zu sprechen was eigentlich eine
sprachhandlung ist und da kann man
bestimmt hier das Ganze weiter auch noch
ausdifferenzieren aber den Wille und den
Wunsch wir wollen heute auch noch mal
das Verhältnis von will und Wunsch
anschauen unter dem Gesichtspunkt von
Willensfreiheit und Handlungsfreiheit
den Begriff des Grunde Hammer und der
steht in einer Spannung zum Begriff der
Willkür wenn man will als bloß
willkürlich versteht ohne Grund ohne
Angabe von Grund dann haben wir die
Rationalität die Vernunft wir könnten
Instrument Telefon von moralischer
Vernunft unterscheiden ein Beispiel für
Instrument Telefon sind die
hypothetischen imperative ein Beispiel
für die moralische von uns sind die
kategorischen operative
können wir dann in eine kritische
Opposition dazu David Hume Stellen der
wie sie alle wissen gesagt hatte es
widerspricht nicht der Vernunft wenn ich
die Vermeidung eines Risses im kleinen
Finger
dem Untergang der ganzen Welt vorziehe
also wenn ich lieber keinen Riss an
meinem kleinen Finger haben möchte als
den Untergang der Welt das sagt David
jung das widerspricht unsere nicht sagen
das verspricht unsere fünf sehr wohl
weil diese Maxime diesen kleinen Finger
oder dass ich lieber selbst nicht leite
und dafür die ganze Menschheit leiden
lassen das würde nach kann er nicht
diesen maximentest bestehen dass ich
meine subjektiven Maxim verallgemeinern
können muss warum nicht müsste man genau
erklären aber jedenfalls kann man das in
Opposition stellen dann Vernunft
natürlich in einer Spannung zu
Willensschwäche und Selbsttäuschung ist
dass wir behandelt werden und selbst
täuschen ist doch eigentlich völlig
irrational wir sollten doch eigentlich
immer versuchen die Wahrheit
herauszufinden aber wir haben die
Tendenz und auch zu täuschen gibt's noch
die Freiheit die kann man unterscheiden
positive Freiheit und negative Freiheit
und man kann Handlungsfreiheit
unterscheiden von
Willensfreiheit dann gibt es hier noch
die Autonomie das ist ein Spezialfall
von Willensfreiheit die immer bekannt
entwickelt hat und bei Autonomie kommt
immer auch die Moral mit ins Spiel also
dieses Gesetz von dem hier die Rede ist
das selbst gegebene Gesetz das ist nach
kann das moralische Gesetz darüber haben
wir das letzte mal ausführlich
diskutiert wir wollen es heute gern noch
ein bisschen fortsetzen und dann gibt es
eben diese drei Formen unserer
Handlung oder unseres Willens nämlich
determination Notwendigkeit oder
Indifferenz also unser Wille und sagen
kann determiniert sein es kann notwendig
netziert sein ist kein festgelegt sein
auf uns in einer Notwendigkeit und es
kann im Differenz sein und dazu verhält
sich auch die Position des
kompatibilismus kompatibilismus heißt
der termination oder der terminiertheit
der Welt oder auch unseres Willens
unserer Handlung ist mit der Freiheit
und kompatibel oder im kompatibilismus
sagt entweder
die Willensfreiheit existiert nicht weil
der Determinismus wahr ist das ist ein
harter Determinismus oder an die es gibt
eine zweite Form des inkompatibilismus
dass der Determinismus falsch ist also
es ist eben nicht so dass alles in der
Welt
reindeterminiert ist es gibt Lücken zum
Beispiel die Naturgesetze könnte man
sagen wie der Termin nicht mehr nicht
alles es gibt Lücken und da passt dann
die will ins Freiheit rein das ist dann
der lieber tarier wissen
muss natürlich dann so ein bisschen auf
Indifferenz rekorieren damit ein
bisschen sich darauf beziehen er muss
Zustände annehmen die nicht ganz
determiniert sind da wo es irgendwie
Spielraum gibt
und der determinist kann trotzdem
behaupten dass der kompatibel ist kann
behaupten dass alles bestimmt ist und
wir trotzdem frei sind jetzt möchte ich
noch mal ein bisschen Rückblicken auf
Handlungsfreiheit und Willensfreiheit
also wir haben gesagt der Wille den
können wir als handlungswirksamen Wunsch
bezeichnen also ein und der ähm in der
Handlung überführt werden soll
nämlich als Seele und jetzt kann man
sich fragen wie wird der Wunsch
handlungswirksam
jetzt gibt es zwei Antworten darauf
entweder als solche weil der Wunsch
einfach der Stärkste ist
wir haben einfach in uns einen Willen
der resultiert aus einem Wunsch und der
ist aber handlungswirksam dann kann man
sagen das ist Handlungsfreiheit es geht
einfach um die Frage was ist unser Wille
welcher Wunsch ist handlungswirksam und
dann geht es um die Frage kann diese
Wille letztendlich in eine Handlung
überführt werden oder auch diese
handlungswirksame Wunsch man kann aber
auch fragen wie ist der Wunsch
handlungswirksam geworden man kann auch
darauf antworten weil wir in diesem
Wunsch willentlich gewisse Maßen
handlungswirksam haben werden lassen
und das wäre dann die Willensfreiheit
das ist so der Unterschied also man kann
einerseits auf den Wunsch oder will
schauen und einfach nur Fragen wird er
in eine Hand
wieder handlungswirksam ist der
handlungswirksam und nicht sich
interessieren wie kam mit dem zustande
sondern es genügt einfach davon
auszugehen wir haben handlungswirksame
wünschen uns oder wir können noch einen
stärkeren Sinne weiter fragen
ja warum ist denn jetzt dieser
wunschhandlungswirksam geworden dann
könnte eine Antwort darauf sein weil wir
es wollten wir wollten dass diese Wunsch
von anderen Wünschen Unterschieden es
gibt ja verschiedene Wünsche die wir
haben handlungswirksam werden und das
ist dann dieses Modell der
Willensfreiheit wie ist Harry Fremdwort
entwickelt hat und jetzt kann man hier
wieder eine kleine Diskussion dazu
machen bevor wir dann übergehen zum
Thema der termination und der
neurologischen das neurologischen
Determinismus
ja und jetzt gehen wir noch mal zurück
auf das Thema
Wolf singer keiner kann anders als er
ist das ist einen Forscher und er hat
hier ein Artikel geschrieben keiner kann
anders als er ist all unser Denken und
Tun ist mit dem ablaufneuronaler
Prozesse zu erklären mein Wolf singer
Direktor Max Planck Institut für
Hirnforschung in Frankfurt wir sollten
aufhören von Freiheit zu reden
das ist jetzt natürlich ein harter
Determinismus weil der sagt dass unsere
Verschaltung uns festlegen mehr noch
genetische Faktoren früher Prägungen
soziale Lernvorgänge und aktuelle
auslöser sind auch viele wünschen und
Argumente andere Zellen wirken stets
untrennbar zusammen und liegen das
Ergebnis fest gleich ob sich
Entscheidungen der unbewussten ohne
bewussten Motiven verdanken sie
bestimmen gemeinsam die dynamischen
Zustände der entscheidende nervensätze
darüber wollen wir auch gleich noch
diskutieren wie sieht's denn aus jetzt
hier sind wir in unserem Handel wollen
genetisch vollständige terminiert machen
sich ihre Gedanken ich bringe noch ein
paar Zitate genetische Positionen können
Verschaltungen hervorgebracht haben wie
das Speichern oder abrufen sozialer
Regeln erschweren und die sozialen
Regeln wurden nicht rechtzeitig und tief
genug eingeprägt oder es wurden von den
Normen abweichende Regeln erlernt oder
die Fähigkeit zu rationalen abwägen
würde wegen fehlgeleiteter Prägung
ungenügend ausdifferenziert diese Liste
ließ sich nahezu beliebig verlängern
keiner kann anders als er ist das ist so
das Stichwort das ist natürlich auch
provokativer Titel wir sind so wie wir
sind Charakter könnte man sagen ne und
der Charakter ist jetzt aber etwas was
rein
hirnorganisch genetisch neuronal
festgelegt ist ich lese noch ein Zitat
vor und dann können wir in die
Diskussion übergehen
diese Einsicht könnte zu einer humanerin
weniger diskriminierenden Beurteilung
von Mitmenschen führen wie das Pech
hatten mit einem Organ volljährig
geworden zu sein dessen funktionelle
Architektur ihnen kein angepasstes
Verhalten erlaubt Menschen mit
problematischen
Verhaltensdispositionen als schlecht
oder böse abzuurteilen bedeutet nichts
anderes als das Ergebnis einer
schicksalshaften Entwicklung des Organs
dass unser Wesen ausmacht zu bewerten
überschreitet das Fehlverhalten eine
Toleranzgrenze tun wir mit Sanktionen
interessanterweise fallen diese
Maßnahmen um so drastische aus je mehr
wir davon ausgehen können das sind die
Linken die Variablen auf denen die
Entscheidung passiert die bewusst sein
müssen
offenbarenden wir Verstöße dann
besonders streng wenn sie gegen explizit
gewusstes begangen werden gegen
Wertordnung also die
überziehungsprozesseentwickler Aktiven
Gedächtnis verankert worden wir
begründen dies indem wir bewusst den
Scheidung ein besonderes Maß an Freiheit
zu schreiben und daraus besonder die
Schuldfähigkeit Verantwortlichkeit und
sanktionsnotwendigkeit ableiten also das
Problem ist wenn wir jetzt unmoralisch
handeln wenn es Menschen gibt die meinen
Banküberfall machen oder dazu Lust haben
dann würde Rolf singer sagen die haben
das Pech gehabt mit einem Organ nämlich
unseren Gehirn volljährig als
strafmündig 18 geworden sein dessen
funktioniert Architektur in kein
angepasstes Verhalten erlaubt
angepasstes Verhalten heißt angepasst an
die Gesetze und die sozialen Regeln ja
wie sieht es aus ich möchte zu
Diskussion geben ist jemand der
unmoralisch handelt so zu verstehen dass
der Pech hatte eigentlich ganz
funktionsfähig ist Gehirn zu haben oder
reicht das nicht aus werden wir so nicht
das Problem lösen können
ja jetzt geht es weiter mit
Sprachhandlungen
das ist ein spannendes Thema dass wir
das letzte Mal schon angerissen hatten
ich hatte gesagt handeln können wir
nicht nur äußeren Sinne mit unseren
Händen Füßen vor allem mit den Händen
sagte das Wort schon Handelns sondern
wir können eben auch handeln mit unserer
Sprache das ist das Besondere dran der
Grundgedanke ist eben nicht nur durch
Einsatz unsere Hände sondern auch durch
den Einsatz unserer Sprache und das sind
sogenannte pechakte oder sprachhandlung
Englisch speech Acts und es gibt ein
paar Beispiele Befehlen kaufen wir gehen
gleich mehr drauf ein und das hier ist
dieses Buch von ausziehen Auto du fängst
mit Word wie können wir Dinge tun mit
Wörtern
durch den Gebrauch der Worte und jetzt
bringt ein paar Beispiele ich habe jetzt
mal versetzt also ja ich will ist eine
sprachhandlung
ich tauche diese Schiff auf den Namen
Queen Elizabeth
ich vermache diese Uhr meiner Tochter an
das sind jetzt natürlich alles
Kontexte die speziell sagt also ja ich
will sie wissen ja das ist die Heirat
wie ich ein Kontext müssen sie sich da
denken damit aus diesem Satz eine
sprachhandlung wird weil wenn sie jetzt
sagen ja ich will was ist dann
nichts was machen sie dann was würden
Sie machen wenn jetzt ich sagen würde ja
ich will jetzt in diesem Moment wie
würden Sie meine meine Vorgehen
beschreiben und meine Handlung
beschreiben
genau ja
richtig genau also es wäre einfach es
wäre ein ein Problem also das ist so
diese dieses die Sache also es geht
nicht darum dass ich etwas will dann
würde ich einfach Ihnen sagen ich will
etwas würden sie fragen was was wollen
Sie ja und darum geht es nicht sondern
es geht darum dass sich ein Willen
bekunde in einem gewissen Kontext
nämlich willst du diese Person heiraten
und
es geht auch nicht nur darum dass ich
sage ich will sie sagen darum geht es
eigentlich auch nicht nur es geht schon
darum auch aber es geht darum dass
dieser Satz einfach durch Konventionen
durch ein bestimmten Kontext durch einen
Setting da ist noch ein Standesbeamten
Standesbeamtin dabei da ist noch
Trauzeuge Trauzeugin dabei dass sie noch
die Hochzeitsgäste dabei oder auch nicht
kann man sich beliebig vorstellen es
muss ein bestimmten Rahmen stattfinden
Standesamt
zivilstandesamt ich weiß gar nicht wie
es bei der kirchlichen Hochzeit ist
glaube auch ja kann man sich jetzt so
oder so überlegen schon lange her mein
Hochzeit muss mal wieder überlegen also
jedenfalls im zivilstandesamt ist es auf
jeden Fall so beim kirchlichen weiß ich
gar nicht mehr und ähm das heißt es geht
darum bestimmten Kontext und da sagen
Sie nicht nur ich will diese Person
heiraten sondern sie gehen damit
Verpflichtungen ein und sie lösen ein
Prozess aus dass ich glaube ja
juristisch rechtlich Sie jetzt die
eingeht vielleicht muss man noch was
unterschreiben da gibt's auch noch so
ein Stifte darum liegt und so ähm und
auch seine Unterschriften ist eigentlich
auch was ähnliches und eine Unterschrift
zu bewegen ihr ihre Hand und damit sind
sie plötzlich verheiratet weil sie da
ihren Namen irgendwie leserlich und
unleserlich auch ein Dokument schreiben
es geht natürlich von Kontexten hängt
das ab und darauf gehen wir jetzt genau
noch ein genauso wenn ich die Uhr
jemanden von mache
oder sag jetzt sagt aus den folgenden in
riesig sampleded zu Archer the sentence
in of course
circumstances das ist entscheidend
den passenden Umständen ist natürlich
Scribe my doing of what I should be set
in southering to be doing or to state
that I'm doing it viel mehr Geld
it is to do it also ich beschreibe nicht
das was ich will sondern ich Ruhe es
indem ich sage
ja das ist das entscheidende when I say
before the registrach or Alter I do I am
Nord reporting on americ ein indoji it
also wenn ich vor einem Standesbeamten
oder einem Altar und so weiter sagen ich
will
dann sage ich nichts über eine Hochzeit
aus sondern ich oder eine Ehe aus ein
Heimat aus und ich vollziehe oder ich
trete in diese diese
ja und wie nennt er jetzt diese
Sprechakte er sagt what are we to call a
sentence orange of disturbe ipropos to
call it performativ sentence or
performative Advents also
performativer Satz
performativ heißt sie kennt das Wort
Performens da vollziehen sie was
da tun Sie was das ist einfach ein Satz
der etwas vollzieht
hier sagte noch was wie schön auf
theaterens is the performing of edge
indem ich einen Satz äußere und indem
ich eine Äußerung von mir gebe
das ist ganz spannend und die
Philosophie hat erst im 20 Jahrhundert
ein Bewusstsein dafür erhalten was er
mit Sprache alles tun können bis dahin
war Sprache vor allem verstanden worden
als
beschreibungsvideo kann etwas
beschreiben etwas darstellen Sprache
stellt die Welt da sie sagt wie es ist
sie reportet sozusagen aber das fand
auch nicht nur etwas beschreiben kann
mit der Sprache ist dann eben auch tun
kann das ist eine recht neue
Einsicht gewesen das hängt auch mit der
Disziplin der Pragmatik zu tun
vielleicht haben Sie das schon mal
gehört Semantik und Pragmatik sie sind
diese Disziplin der linke ist dick sie
können Sätze dahin untergehen
untersuchen was darin für eine Bedeutung
ausgedrückt ist die Bedeutung von
Wörtern von Sätzen oder Sie können
fragen was tue ich indem ich etwas sagen
dieses was sie tun ist die Kürze
Disziplin der Pragmatik
also Handlung als sprachhandlung wir
können handeln bzw unseren Willen kausal
verwirklichen die wir unsere Lippen
bewegen und lauter produzieren nämlich
bequem ist natürlich auch sehr effizient
dass wir so handeln können das was wir
sagen und das Schreiben jetzt kommt muss
jedoch vielen Gesetzen gehorchen und es
bedarf zahlreiche Voraussetzungen damit
wir überhaupt von sprachhandlung reden
können wenn ich jetzt einfach sage ich
will passiert hier gar nichts dann
fragen sie wie sie zurecht getan hat was
wollen Sie denn ja eigentlich ja das
heißt es gibt Voraussetzung damit ich
überhaupt eine sprachhandlung vollziehen
kann und es ist die Syntax
als Syntax ist der Satzbau ich muss
natürlich den Satz des Satz muss
wohlgeformt sein obwohl ich will ist ja
auch irgendwie ein bisschen
unvollständig ja natürlich muss man
fragen willst du das xy und dann ist die
Frage ich will das muss man sich noch
dazu denken Syntax also der Satzbau die
Grammatik
Dramatik natürlich ihren geschriebenen
ja die Semantik die Bedeutung der Wörter
muss geklärt sein die ich verwende ich
kann nicht irgendwie in die falsche
Wortstellung im Satz gebrauchen oder das
das falsche Wort dann nehmen wenn ich
einfach Probleme in der Wortfindung habe
aber wenn man sie fragt wollen Sie jetzt
diese Person heiraten und sie sagen ja
ich würde
ja ich würde
geht nicht können Sie mal versuchen
aber ich glaube es klappt nicht
oder ja ich wünsche ja dann vielleicht
ich wünsche es zu tun aber wir sagen ja
ich würde oder ja er wird oder ja sie
wird es klappt nicht ja es muss
irgendwie schon eine wohlgeformte
Struktur haben und Sie können natürlich
müssen natürlich auch die Pragmatik noch
berücksichtigen
Pragmatik ist eben das was sie tun und
das entscheiden ist die sozialen rege
das fasse ich jetzt sehr weit dazu
gehört natürlich auch die Gesetze dazu
gehört die Ordnung im Standesamt dazu
gehört einfach ich weiß jetzt gar nicht
wo die standesamtlich Ordnung verankert
ist im Gesetz ich bin ja kein Jurist
aber das muss dann irgendwie auch
vielleicht öffentliches Recht sein oder
keine Ahnung also irgendwo muss es auch
richtig verankert sein und nur wenn
diese gewissen Gesetze bürgerliche
bürgerliches Gesetzbuch keine Ahnung
wenn die Geld gelten nur dann kann ich
eben so eine sprachhandlung vollziehen
dass der Satz ja ich will in bestimmten
Kontext zu einer Ehe führt und das
Eingehen eine Ehe bedeutet
das ist ganz wichtig also sie können
hier nicht einfach sagen ich kann jetzt
mit meinen Worten beliebiges tun sondern
sie müssen schon diese Kontexte
vorfinden damit sie damit in diesen
Kontexten diese Äußerung zu einer Hand
als dieselbe sprachhandlung kann einem
Kontext zu nichts führen dieselbe
Äußerung genau genommen keine einem
Kontext zu nichts führen oder zu fragen
berechtigten Rückfragen wenn ich sage ja
ich will dann kommt die richtige Frage
was wollen Sie wenn ich sie in einem
höher sein wenn ich in einem Standesamt
sagt zusammen mit einer Partnerin mit
dann ist Beamtin mit Trauzeugen dann
wird daraus was anderes es ist ganz
wichtig dieser Kontext
so jetzt machen wir eine kleine
diskussionshunde und dann geht es weiter
zu den Gefühlen und Emotionen
ja jetzt wollen wir uns noch zum Ende
mit dem Thema Emotionen befassen das ist
ein spannendes Thema was
ja was auch im Kontext der
Handlungstheorie diskutiert werden muss
Gefühl und Emotionen was ist eigentlich
eine Emotion kann man sich Fragen
liefern unterscheiden sich Emotionen von
Gefühlen
können Emotionen rational sein
was bedeuten Emotionen
wie verhalten sich Wille und
Rationalität in Emotionen muss natürlich
immer erst fragen was sind eigentlich
Emotionen eben auch die Frage liefern
können Emotionen zum Handeln motivieren
wir haben bisher immer nur so getan als
ob es um die Rationalität ginge Gründe
wir wollen uns letztendlich Fragen
können Emotionen auch Gründe für unser
Handeln nein oder sind Emotionen
Störfaktoren die nichts zu suchen haben
wenn es ums Handeln geht dass die Frage
und jetzt fragen uns mal was ist
eigentlich eine Emotion eine riesen
Frage wie alle Fragen der Philosophie
gibt es da ganz viele Auffassung darüber
was ich Ihnen jetzt präsentiere ist
erwachsen aus einem Seminar was ich mal
gegeben habe aber Emotionen aber darüber
kann man auch schreiben es gibt was
Emotionen die die Unterscheidung
zwischen Gefühlen perfekt den Stimmungen
Emotionen ist ein heißes Thema in der
Philosophie das wollte ich immer sagen
sie könnte auch immer andere Meinung
sein wenn sie Argumente haben jetzt
nicht mal so ein paar Vorschläge von
Emotionen bringen weil die folgenden
Sitzung werden nur auch uns mit
moralischen Emotionen befassen
moralischen Gefühlen und unmoralische
Motivation das heißt eben auch die Frage
können uns diese Emotionen oder Gefühle
dafür der Stimmung auch zum Handeln
motivieren
ich bringe jetzt meine ganze Reihe von
Phänomen die in meinen Augen Emotionen
sind Mitleid zum Beispiel da ist ein
Philosoph David jung und Auto schoben
die sagen Mitleid ist die entscheidende
Emotion sage ich jetzt mal manche sagen
auch gefühlt
perfekt ich sag's Emotionen die uns auch
zum Handeln antreibt und die uns zum
Handel antreiben soll Mitleid ist fast
normatives Mitleid hat in sich einen
Wert Mitleid führt wenn es zu Motiv
interessantes wird nach schuppenmauer
zumindest immer zur guten Handlung
Immanuel Kant bestreitet das übrigens
Alter sehen sie wieder da kann man sich
schön drüber streiten die Achtung
also das moralische Gefühl der Achtung
erkannt ich glaube es eine Emotionen
wenn sie Hochachtung vor einer Person
haben also sie Respekt also ich gebe
Ihnen mal ein Beispiel
Stichwort Konstanz Halbmarathon ja
angenommen ich laufe dir den 50 Minuten
schaffe ich nie dann könnten sie sagen
Respekt das ist eine gute Leistung aber
hätten sie auch Hochachtung von dem
moralische Achtung dass man eben kann
ist nicht dasselbe ja aber da kommt die
berühmte Person rein ich habe ich habe
Respekt vor mir irgendwie keine Ahnung
Superstar das muss unterschieden werden
von moralische Hochachtung die wir nur
Personen gegen bringt die für uns ein
moralisches Beispiel sind ja wenn sie
sehen wie ein eine Person sich verletzt
und eine andere Person hilft dir sofort
oder ein kleines Kind will ist gerade
mit Trinken im Bodensee und einen mutige
Person springt hinterher und rette das
Kind ganz uneigent sich dann haben Sie
vielleicht moralische Achtung weil sie
sagen dann diese Person hat vorbildlich
gehandelt das sagt immer man kann das
ist Achtung und dann gibt's noch die
Emotion der Scham
sind auch ein ganz spannendes von Linken
Scham da hat Max schähler dazu was
gemacht Friedrich Schleim machen der
Ekel Jean Paul zartre und wir werden
auch diese Emotionen mein Augen sind
Emotionen auch mal genauer behandeln die
Verzweiflung
die Angst war den heiliger und der Neid
und die Eifersucht der Neid ist auch ein
ganz interessantes Phänomen was wir
behandeln müssen wenn es ums Handeln
geht und nicht zuletzt darauf geht es
heute darüber heute eingehen die Liebe
also welche Rolle spielt die Liebe jetzt
bei unseren Hand natürlich hängt die
Frage immer davon ab was ist eigentlich
liebe kann er ganz verschiedene sein wir
haben mal kurz darüber gesprochen was
Liebe ist versteht jeder was anderes
drunter wir müssen uns überlegen welchen
Kontexten wie ich im Sinn ist Liebe
überhaupt
ein Grund für unsere Hand kann die Band
sein jetzt möchte ich mal verschiedene
Phänomene behandeln oder auch Begriffe
Emotionen Affekte Gefühle und Stimmungen
ja das ist gar nicht klar was ist
eigentlich der Unterschied ja
darüber würde ich jetzt mal kurz mit ihm
diskutieren was sie glauben was der
Unterschied zwischen diesen Formen hier
eigentlich ist
also es geht darum wie verhalten sich
diese verschiedenen Phänomene zueinander
können wir sie klar voneinander
unterscheiden können wir Kriterien geben
Oberbegriffe wie wir sie voneinander
abgrenzen können und zwar möglichst
objektiv ohne Handlungsspielraum
und jetzt habe ich hier was vorbereitet
eine Tabelle und zwar Sie die folgende
Maßen aus
ich würde sagen Emotionen sind ein
stabiler Ausdruck starker Subjektivität
ich würde sagen wir nehmen zwei
Kriterien bis der Ausdruck stabil oder
ist er
kurzfristig und wird unsere
Innerlichkeit
dauert ausgedrückt oder nur schwach und
meine These wäre jetzt Gefühle sein
äußerlicher Eindruck der nicht ein
innerlicher Ausdruck ist also zum
Beispiel könnte man sagen Gefühle sind
Hungergefühl im Hungergefühl drücke ich
nicht mich selbst aus als mein Wesen
immer drücke ich nicht eine
Subjektivität aus ein inneren
Zustand sind ein Gefühl kann auch ein
Schmerzgefühl sein was mir eher von
außen kommt sicherlich könnte man sagen
Hungergefühl kommt irgendwie auch aus
innen aus dem Inneren aber sie würden
wohl nie sagen dass ich Hunger ihre
Subjektivität ausdrückt anders als in
der Liebe oder vielleicht auch ein
Affekt so mein Vorschlag man kann den
Affekt als ein instabilen instabil meine
ich eben nicht so lange anhalten
Ausdruck starker Subjektivität verstehen
also der Effekt der motiviert und Stärke
der hat mehr Kraft und die Stimmung
könnte man als stabilen Ausdruck als als
längerfristige Ausdruck einer schwachen
Subjektivität besteht jetzt habe ich da
mal jetzt Schema gemacht
und darüber kann man diskutieren also
ich habe jetzt hier Beispiele gebracht
ich glaube also wir können Phänomen
unterscheiden Emotion Gefühl Affekt
Stimmung wir können es jetzt
unterscheiden die Subjektivität und
Extension mit Extension meine ich ist es
stabil längerfristig wie eine Stimmung
oder ist nur momentan
jetzt gehen wir mal die Beispiel durch
wir haben Achtung Hunger gut und Glück
Trauer statt Achtung also Achtung ist
für mich ein Emotion wir können aber
auch liebe einfügen Liebe ist vielleicht
besser Liebe wäre nach meiner
Vorstellung stabil ich liebe jemand
nicht nur eine
Frage was für liebesgefangen aber nehmen
Sie mal den liebesbegriff der vielleicht
eine Beziehung gilt ja dass Sie Ihr
Partner ihre Ehepartnerin lieben oder
ihr Freund ihre Freundin lieben dann
lieben sie die nicht irgendwie mal nur
so eine Sekunde oder zwei Sekunden oder
5 Sekunden wie sie ein Effekt haben der
Wurzeln längerfristig es kann auch mal
auf und abgehen aber er hat eher so ein
Stabilität und die Subjektivität die
sich daran ausdrückt ist recht stark sie
drücken sich darin aus in der Liebe es
hat einen stark persönlich persönlich
ausdrücken will
Hunger hingehen wäre jetzt für mich ein
Gefühl weil es recht momentan sind nicht
so lange hungrig wie sie jemanden lieben
würde ich sagen vielleicht schon weiß
nicht und er ist ein schwacher Ausdruck
ihrer Subjektivitäten im Hungergefühl
drückt sich nicht so sehr ihre
Subjektivität aus wie im Lee in der
liebes Emotion nehmen wir mal den Affekt
die Wut die Wut ist momentan die strikt
sich nicht zehn Tage lang oder zwei
Jahre oder ein ganzes Leben wie die
Liebe vielleicht bei manchen Paaren hält
keine Ahnung die Wut ist kurzfristiger
ihre Ausdehnung Extension heißt
Ausdehnung ist er punktuell und nicht so
lang erstrecken stabil und die Wut ist
aber ein starker Ausdruck unserer mit
diskutieren gleich unser
Subjektivität im Gegensatz zum Gefühl
und jetzt muss ich noch die Stimmung
davon unterscheiden wie zum Beispiel
Trauer eine Stimmung der Trauer die
Ausstellung ist recht stabil eine
Stimmung erstreckt sich länger
und sie ist aber darüber kann man jetzt
diskutieren in meinen Augen eher ein
schwacher Ausdruck unseres Subjektivität
und kann deswegen auch nicht so gut zum
Handeln motivieren wie zum Beispiel
einer Effekt oder zum Handeln treiben
wie ein Effekt oder eine Emotion und
meine These wäre die Emotion ist dadurch
vom Effekt ausgezeichnet und kann
deswegen als Grund für unsere Effekt
nicht perfekt sind meines Erachtens
keine guten Gründe von zu handeln weil
wir darin ja gar nicht zurechenbar sind
wenn sie oder nicht voll zu reden ja
Mord im Effekt wird ein irgendwie dann
doch auch nicht nachgesehen aber es wird
dann geht dann mildert Umstände
vielleicht wenn sie nicht ganz sicher
waren das heißt Emotionen sind deswegen
vor Effekten ausgezeichnet als mögliche
Gründe unseres handeln weil sie eben
stabil sind weil sie sich längerfristig
erstrecken und deswegen kontrolliert
werden können und eben Affekte nicht
jetzt möchte ich jemand noch was
überlegen also nur
Subjektivität kann uns motiviert
wirklich zum Handeln nicht schwache also
Gefühle sicherlich auch bestimmten Grad
aber Affekte oder Emotionen sind stärker
und
dagegen muss man aber sagen dass hier
bei der Emotion noch die Reflexion
reinkommt weil es nicht eine Emotion
nicht wie ein Effekt momentan impulsiv
geschieht sondern eine Emotion hat er
eine Ruhe hat er eine Stabilität und die
ermöglicht dann eine Flexion das heißt
nach meiner Auffassung dieses
Schnittmenge hier davon motivationalen
Aspekt kann sie uns antreiben ist
Phänomen ist stark genug und reflexiven
Aspekt wäre für mich die Emotion ein
guter Fall als Grund für das handelt
dienen zu können wir haben Harry Potter
der hat ein Buch geschrieben
love es gibt auch noch ein Buch das
heißt ein riesenauflage die Gründe der
Liebe deutsche Übersetzung Gründe liebe
das sagt schon alles die Liebe ist ein
Grund von der Handel sagt er
jetzt lese ich ihn noch ein Zitat vor
loving someone all something essentually
meets or consisten
Ammans for actions to surf those
interest love is itself for the Lover
source of reasons it createst the
reasons by which his acts of loving
concern and devotion
also liebe ist selbst für die liebende
Person eine Quelle von Gründen
und er sagt one distingte feature of
loving has to do with particula status
of the valley Tod ins Objekts es geht
also darum dass wir wenn wir etwas
lieben das wieder mit Werte verbinden
Liebe als Emotion geht einen Wert ähm
wir haben jetzt nicht mehr viel Zeit
trotzdem würde ich sie noch gerne bitten
zu einer Diskussion können Emotionen
Gründe für unsere Hand